hello everyone welcome to the broadcast
of our keynote presentation
reinforcement learning mechanisms and
implications it is presented by n mod as
kandar MD professor and chairman in the
Department of Neurological Surgery at
the Albert Einstein College of Medicine
at the Montefiore Medical Center I am
Judy Oracle glaber's and I'll be your
moderator for today's events we are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab roots lab
Ruth is the leading scientific social
networking website and producer of
educational virtual events and webinars
before we begin I would like to remind
everyone this event is interactive we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
anytime you want during the presentation
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
and type your questions into the
drop-down box that appears on the screen
will answer as many questions as we have
time for at the end of the presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation please click on the
help desk button located in the
promotional board at the bottom center
of your screen or use the ask a question
box to let us know that you're having a
problem this presentation is educational
and thus offers continuing education
credits please click on the continuing
education credits tab located in the top
right corner of the presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming dr.
s kandar I will now turn the
presentation over to him
well thank you for that wonderful
introduction and as you heard today I'm
gonna be talking about reinforcement
learning it's mechanisms and potential
implications so we will start by
reviewing the anatomy of the basal
ganglia
which play a critical part in
reinforcement learning and it's
important to recognize that there are in
fact multiple parallel loops through the
basal ganglia
there's the commonly studied motor loop
which is involved in Parkinson's disease
but there was also the executive and the
motivational which are involved in
cognition and decision-making
respectively and the basal ganglia can
be thought of as first having a set of
input nuclei or the striatum
collectively that includes the putamen
the caudate and the nucleus accumbens
then output nuclei the Globus pallidus
internus and the substantial [ __ ] pars
reticulata and for most of our
discussion today we're gonna focus on
the motor and executive pathways and the
caudate and the nucleus accumbens that's
illustrated here where you have the
various structures involved in the
different loops and we're gonna be
concentrating on the largely on the
executive so that includes the
essentially the caudate and we're also
gonna look some at the limbic loop which
involves eventual strain now this area
the anterior striatum is very
interesting so what you see on the left
is a set of coronal images with staining
demonstrating where the connections
different cortical areas are and you can
see that there's a very significant
representation of broad areas of the
frontal cortex in the striatum including
the dorsal lateral prefrontal cortex the
dorsal anterior cingulate cortex and
others in addition we all know that this
area gets a very rich dopaminergic
innervation as you can see on the image
on the right the lower right now
dopamine is very important and we tend
to think of it as tonic dopamine levels
and
and motor disorders like Parkinson's
disease but there's also phasic dopamine
release related to reward specifically
whether there's an expected or an
unexpected reward so this is a figure
from a summer work by Wolfram Schultz
where they performed recordings from
dopaminergic neurons in the midbrain of
an awake behaving primate that was
performing a behavioral task and
initially the animal pulls on the
joystick and gets a juice reward and if
you can see in the upper Instagram that
there's phasic dopamine release directly
after the animal gets to more overtime
that reward is paired with something
like a visual stimulus or an auditory
cue and then you can see that the
dopamine release now occurs at the time
that the cue occurs which anticipates
the reward and then interestingly if on
occasion you will make that reward you
actually see a drop off in the dopamine
release and so this has led to the idea
that dopamine signals a reward
prediction error where unexpectedly good
outcomes lead to an increase in dopamine
release so that's a positive reward
prediction error and ultimately
reinforcement of the behavior that led
to that reward expected good outcomes
lead to a steady state and a zero reward
prediction error and then unexpectedly
bad outcomes
have a negative prediction error and
presumably lead to a reduction in the
behavior
there's also cellular models that fit in
with this idea where if you stimulate
quartic Australian or synapses they can
have a prolonged period of facilitation
so there's a cellular mechanism whereby
the dopamine can actually get a
prolonged facilitation that lasts up to
20 minutes so kind of putting it all
together this idea
reinforcement learning and you can sort
of imagine this circuitry here where the
cortex and the caudate are densely
interconnected and then the animals or
person is sort of behaving so let's
imagine in this case it's a monkey the
monkey sees the banana tree is
illustrated up there on the left it
climbs that tree and he finds that there
are bananas there and when that happens
initially it's unexpected and so there's
an increase in midbrain dopaminergic
release which then causes reinforcement
of the particular subset of circuits
that led to that behavior then over time
that behavior gets reinforced and then
as and then they add dopamine release
sort of goes back to the its baseline
this is basically a simple way of
understanding you know the various
things that we've seen so far so based
on this we wanted to study some ideas
hypotheses one that the caudate nucleus
plays a critical role in learning to the
dopamine is important in reinforcing
associations and three that somehow
modulating the dopamine release can lead
to enhanced learning use a weak behaving
non-human primates and this is a
standard physiology set up on the left
you see the instrument rack on the upper
right you see the where the animal sits
and the screen that it's viewing and the
lower right is a coronal MRI
demonstrating the brain and then the
chamber place that allows access to all
of the necessary areas this is a basic
task that we've used this is an
associative learning task you think on
the left this is the first screen that
the animal sees it's basically a central
fixation point
with four great targets around it and
then a new stimulus comes up in the
middle of something that the animal has
never seen before and then the fixation
point changes color then the animal has
to figure out which target to go to
essentially by trial and error let's say
in this case the animal chooses the
right target then the animal would get a
tone indicating that it received the
award the reward excuse me ultimately an
apple juice reward so you could imagine
there's four targets so there are four
new stimuli one associated one uniquely
associated with each target and over
time the animal learns these four
different associations but it's not a
meeting it takes multiple trials to get
that so this is an example of group data
from recordings in the caudate nucleus
of an awake behaving animal and the
graph in the center shows a number of
things the blue line shows the animals
learning curve so the animal starts at
about 25% which is essentially chance
there's four targets so one out of four
targets means he's gonna get it right
about 25% of the time and as he starts
to learn the it curves upward there's a
steep part of the learning curve where
he's starting to make and consolidating
the associations and then finding the
curve sort of plateaus once he's
mastered the Association around 85% so
that's the X is actually a group
learning curve and then the black line
represents the group or population
neuronal data from the caudate nucleus
and the most interesting thing about it
is that it really peaks during the steep
part of the learning curve when the
animals actively making new associations
and that's approximated by taking the
first derivative of the learning curve
so there's relatively little activity in
the beginning when animals naive the
relatively little activity at the end
when the animals mastered the
Association and the peak of activity
occurs when the animal was actually
learning and this occurs primarily
during the feedback period of the task
so once the animal has learned whether
he has gotten the trial correct or not
correct
now we done mistake in this research
further and look
this activity in the caudate and the
dorsal lateral prefrontal cortex and
these are single unit examples and the
colored lines differs represent
different outcomes so expected positive
rewards green is unexpected positive
rewards red is expected negative rewards
and blue is unexpected negative rewards
and what's interesting is that the
neurons seem to represent unexpected the
positive rewards which fits in with the
reinforcement learning model but they
also in some cases respond to unexpected
negative outcomes so the right-hand
graph shows a neuron that responds to
unexpected positive rewards and the
right-hand one represents a response to
unexpected negative reward and we
actually found many neurons of both
kinds in both structures the caudate and
the dorsal lateral prefrontal cortex so
this table summarizes it and the small
table it's hard to see but the point is
that there's actually a significant
number of neurons that respond to
unexpected negative outcomes about the
same percentage 70% as those that
respond to unexpected positive outcomes
so it's pretty fairly this trip evenly
distributed it doesn't quite fit with
the existing law now we've also looked
at this in humans and this is a somewhat
different tasks so in this case we're
actually recording in humans that are
having deep brain stimulation surgery
and we're planning to put electrodes in
the nucleus accumbens or the ventral
striatum so on the right is sort of is
an illustration of a patient being
prepared for surgery you can see the top
of the patient's head and you can see
the video monitor there and once we're
doing the operation and we're doing
microelectrode recordings for placement
of the electrodes and we perform the
experiment when the experiment is a
gambling task which is illustrated in
the lower row there so in this case
which starts with the patient fixating
on a dot
and then the patient gets his or her
card and then the patient is forced to
make a bet as to whether the computers
card is going to be higher or lower and
if the patient is correct well then and
then the computer flips its card and
then depending on the outcome yeah they
get a screen that says they won $20 or
they lost $20 so it allows us an
opportunity to see what happens with
expected and unexpected outcomes so in
the middle upper panel there you can see
the patient's reaction times and it
basically follows what one would think
that is the reaction times are quite
fast for the 2 and the 10 card so
they're sort of no-brainers if you will
you're always going to lose on a 2 and
always gonna win on a 10 and then there
are action times a little bit longer for
the 4 6 and 8 cards because they require
some thought and then on the right you
see the percentage of bets so again
people perform a reasonably rational
manner so most of the time they bet low
on the to card and then most of the time
they bet high on the 10 card so their
behavior basically tracks what we
expected to do now while we're doing
this we recorded neurons in the nucleus
accumbens and they also exhibited this
response to unexpectedly positive
outcomes so as you can see in the upper
panel there's a big difference there
between unexpected wins and then
unexpected losses and then expected wins
and expected losses so very little
effect we didn't clearly see a big
response to unexpected losses unlike
what we saw in the primate and it's
unclear if that has to do with the
location being a different structure or
a task because it's not using actual
food or juice or just maybe a sampling
issue because we had many fewer neurons
in humans than we did in primates but
it's interesting nonetheless and another
interesting feature we
is has to do with the six cards so the
sixth card is right in the middle of the
spectrum basically there's a 50-50
chance of either winning or losing and
the patient can choose whichever way
they want to go and what we found is
that the activity in the nucleus
accumbens which is illustrated in the
lower left-hand panel actually predicts
what the subjects is going to do about
two seconds before they actually do it
so this is a really interesting finding
indicating that there's some disposition
or sort of intuition that the subject
has and it's already manifest in the
brain you know a whole two seconds
before they actually perform with you so
to summarize this bit by recordings from
the human nucleus accumbens the patients
behave rationally single neurons encode
unexpected wins and losses
although the wins are more prominent and
that part is consistent with their work
prediction error and interestingly
single neurons seem to encode the
subjects expectation or intuition when
the visual cue is sort of is neutral
basically there's an equal probability
of winning or losing
we want to investigate the role that
dopamine might play into this and
particularly what happens with
electrical stimulation which is one of
the ways we have to modulate
dopaminergic function so we use a
technique called fixed potential and per
AMA tree and if you can see in the right
upper hand panel there are two
electrodes and there's a stimulating
electrode and a carbon-fibre electrode
and the carbon fiber electrode has its
potential clamped at 0.8 volts which is
near the oxidation potential of dopamine
and then any dopamine molecules that are
in the vicinity of electrode can attach
to it and they become oxidized and
donate to electrons and that can be
detected as a small current then we can
look very specifically at the effects of
stimulation and what it does to the
local dopamine transmission as you can
see in the lower panel that with brief
pulses of stimulation in white
matter above the caudate you don't see a
dopaminergic current and once you get in
the body of the caudate and the lower
two traces there is an actual
dopaminergic current and then next we
explored the differences between high
and low frequency stimulation and this
is best illustrated in the lower panel
so with low frequency stimulation at 20
Hertz you don't see much of a change in
the dopaminergic current there's a
little increase with each stimulus pulse
and then it relaxes back to normal if
you go into 200 Hertz that's the black
trace see there's actually a significant
increase in dopamine release that's
sustained for the period of the
stimulation which in this case is one
second so this gives us a mechanism
whereby we can potentially modulate the
vocal phasic levels of dopamine and
determine their effect on learning and
the real question is can we have time
stimulation that sort of mimics the
natural dopamine release and would that
modulate learning in any way so like I
showed you previously it's the same
circuitry and the idea is that the
stimulation is modulating and enhancing
the phasic dopamine levels so we
actually did these kinds of experiments
where the animals perform the same
associative learning tasks that I showed
you before but then during the feedback
period of correct trials they got
high-frequency stimulation so specific
stimulation occurring at a certain time
and after correct trials or as a control
after incorrect trials that's the basic
paradigm and at first we thought that
this was somehow I was just disrupt
learning or kind of screw it all up but
in fact what we found is that this type
of high-frequency stimulation actually
enhances learning so here's a segment of
the learning curve and control is in
black and then in blue is
the learning curve with stimulation you
can see is that the learning is better
it's it's faster than occurs in the
normal state and then we looked at high
frequency and low frequency stimulation
and we can only really see the effect
with high frequency stimulation so the
blue line is is higher than the black
line low frequency stimulation which is
a red line really didn't show the same
effect and interestingly unstimulated
trials in the same session didn't show
an effect so the effect wasn't sort of
spilling over or leaking over unto other
other trial types and then we looked at
stimulation following correct and
incorrect trials so again the baseline
learning curve is in black the blue line
represents learning with stimulation
after correct trials and so we see the
enhancement of learning and then the red
line shows what happens if we stimulate
after incorrect trials and here it's
very interesting because it seems that
stimulation after incorrect trials
actually retards learning it slows down
learning it says if the animal has to
sort of work its way around this
associate is inappropriate Association
to ultimately learn what needs to be
learned since then that was about ten
years ago we've repeated this experiment
and used combined stimulation in both
the caudate nucleus and the nucleus
accumbens with the idea that the caudate
nucleus is involved in learning and the
nucleus accumbens is involved in
motivation and what we found was that
combined stimulation actually leads to
very profound increase in learning so if
you look at the black line that's the
baseline and then the Green Line is the
stimulation and the caudate nucleus and
the red line is combined stimulation and
in this case we really get a very
significant effect both in terms of the
speed of learning and in the final
performance show not only the animals
faster but they're become more accurate
so we find that this was very
interesting and this is recently
published in 2016 so given what we've
learned here so far you know we can
reasonably conclude that the caudate
nucleus plays an important role in
learning that dopamine is potentially
important in reinforcing associations
that stimulation after correct trials
results in enhanced learning but
possibly due to hands dopamine release
where stimulation after incorrect trials
seems to [ __ ] alert and so this led us
to the question of could you use this
type of stimulation to enhance the
recovery or the learning after some type
of brain injury could you use this in
some viable clinical scenario so to do
this we created a mouse model of
traumatic brain injury this slide shows
a histology slide of the mouse brain and
as you can see the red hair there shows
the area that's been damaged by using a
controlled cortical impact and then this
is the model that we then used to
evaluate this potential treatment and
then the animals basically perform on
the Morris water maze so imagine that
the animal has the TBI the traumatic
brain injury and then they have an
electrode implanted and then they have
to swim around this maze as shown in the
upper right hand side so they swim from
the edge to a platform that's hidden
they can see it from the surface of the
water and there are visual cues on the
sides that indicate to them where to go
and the two lower panels show deliberate
electrolytic lesions that we made and
nucleus accumbens and the caudate
nucleus to confirm that we were in the
right place and we found is that there
was indeed an enhancement in their
learning on this water maze task so
these are different search patterns that
the animals had with and without
stimulation so the dashed blue
represents the court of animals that
no stimulation and you can see that even
by day five they're still sort of pretty
lost and they're swimming all over the
place whereas the red lion represents
animals that had stimulation after they
reach the platform and you can see they
have much more much shorter and much
more deliberate search paths and this
can be quantified as the escape latency
which is the time it takes them to find
the hidden platform which is very
similar to the learning curve which is
going in the opposite direction so in
this case that black line indicates the
normals the controls and they have a
gradual improvement in their escape
latency the red line represents the
injured animals that don't get
stimulation and so they do not perform
well and they continue to not perform
well and then the blue line represents
animals that had a brain injury and had
the stimulation and you can see they
have an improvement in their and their
learning and start to approach the
control animals we also wanted to test
if this effect was durable or if it was
sort of evanescent so in a subset of
these animals we stopped stimulation
after five days waited 10 days and then
tested them again at 15 days and what
you see is that there is a significant
retention of the learned material so the
black and the blue lines that is the
control and the stimulated animals
essentially started at the same point so
it's not that they forgotten or that
it's evanescent the effect is still
persistent and then ultimately the the
injured animals in the red line
eventually start to get better but they
never get quite as good as the as the
control animals or the animals that
received stimulation you also tested
this in humans so as part of a separate
project where we had electrodes
implanted into the brain for the
purposes of seizure localization we had
an opportunity to test three patients
and to determine whether we could see a
similar phenomenon and these results are
illustrated
here so this is this is the learning in
three different human subjects panels a
and B represent the learning curves
where the electrodes were close to the
caudate or in the caudate and the blue
line indicates the the presence of
stimulation and the red line indicates
that they were not stimulated and so on
both of these patients there was indeed
an effect of stimulation on on learning
as expected and predicted by the rodents
and the primate studies panel see shows
a subject in which the electrode was
closer to the putamen and there you
don't see a learning effect so it's very
specific to the caudate and this slide
summarizes these findings effectively
you've seen this learning enhancement
across three species now starting with
the mouse where we use the Morris water
maze and then going to the non-human
primate we've repeatedly shown this
enhancement of learning and then finally
in a limited number of human subjects
but still saw the same finding so this
gives us a lot of confidence that yeah
this is a real effect particularly that
we can find it across three species and
using different behavioral tasks so this
kind of brings us to the end of the talk
and so you know things that we can feel
comfortable about that the caudate and
the dorsal lateral prefrontal cortex
respond to unexpected positive outcomes
consistent with the reward prediction
error interestingly the caudate and
dorsal lateral prefrontal cortex neurons
also respond to unexpected negative
outcomes and so the questions that are
outstanding you know for us or really
what's behind this this response to
negative outcomes is it is a drop-off
and dopamine release and that may be the
case but the signals seem to have equal
amplitudes and based on the dopaminergic
signal it doesn't look like there's
enough bandwidth to get this negative
response is the dopaminergic neurons
fire tonically at like five Hertz so you
can only go down to zero but they can go
up to like you know
thirty Hertz so it's not clear whether
that's sufficient to represent this
response to unexpected negative outcomes
so there are a number of other
possibilities it could be other
neurotransmitters or at play
it could be somehow embedded in the in
the circuit dynamics but it's a very
important thing because obviously
learning requires both learning new
associations and unlearning forgetting
discarding useless or maladaptive
associations so to learn optimally the
subject needs to do both things well and
then it requests the stimulation you
know we found that stimulation after
correct trials needs to enhance learning
in the rodent the primate and the human
and so you know the question is could
these be useful enhancing recovery after
some type of brain injury traumatic
brain injury stroke and so we're hopeful
that we can start evaluating this in a
pilot trial in humans in the near future
and as I pointed out one of the other
interesting findings though is that
stimulation after incorrect trials
retards learning it slows down learning
and so could you use some certain type
of stimulation to mimic the response to
unexpected negative outcomes and more
broadly could you use that to weaken
maladaptive associations so on the one
hand we want to reinforce learning and
brain injury patients but you there are
any number of conditions where somebody
might have some persistent behaviors or
associations that are they're not
helping them for instance Hicks and
Tourette's syndrome could be
conceptualized as a maladaptive
Association similarly obsessions and
compulsions and obsessive compulsive
disorder can be looked at as maladaptive
associations and for instance triggers
for smoking or other types of substance
abuse can be looked at as maladaptive
associations and so the question is can
you
use stimulation in a deliberate fashion
to weaken these associations and
possibly replace them with other more
useful associations so my mind those are
some of the big questions but they are
you know of course many others to
consider so that concludes my talk and
thank you very much and I look forward
to answering any questions thank you dr.
s kandar for that informative
presentation we will now start the live
Q&A portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question
drop-down box located on the far left of
your presentation window type your
question into the box that appears on
your screen
and click the send button will answer as
many of your questions as we have time
for let's get started this question is
how do you know the learning effect is
not due to reward so that's a really
good question that is how do you know
that the effect isn't simply perception
on the subjects part that this is just
an enhanced reward and I didn't show
this data but we actually looked at this
very carefully so we for instance did
experiments where the animal had a
choice between getting juice or getting
stimulation and 90 some percent of time
they selected the juice but also the
experiments were they had two conditions
one of just juice and one of juice plus
stimulation and they picked at about 50%
so that tells us that they don't
perceive the stimulation as in any way
rewarding or hedonic or positive and
it's well below the levels that have
historically been used for you know
intracranial soft stimulation so we're
operating and possibly up to one
milliamp and those older studies have
used all the way up to ten milliamps
so we really don't think it's somehow
enhanced reward effects well thank you
the next one is how specific is the
learning effect this is a really good
question and
I'll answer that in two parts one is we
haven't really fully tested if this
generalizes in any way she's relatively
specific when the question is where does
this specificity arise and I think it
arises from the circuitry kind of as I
showed in the beginning that is for any
given behavior there's a subset of
circuits that becomes activated and it's
that subset that then gets facilitated
if the behavior leads to unexpectedly
good outcome so the stimulation doesn't
have to be very specific
it's the circuits that are specific and
I think that's how we achieve this
effect it's still to be determined
whether it generalizes in some way to
other related behaviors the next one how
durable is the learning enhancement this
is also a really good question and you
know the best answer we have for that is
from the rodent experiments as you
recall in those experiments we stopped
stimulating and then evaluated animals
ten days later and the effect seems to
persist completely in that the
stimulated animals and the controls were
started at the same place that's as long
as we looked but that seems to suggest
that 10 days would be certainly long
enough to make a difference in someone's
rehabilitation or learning I would like
to once again thank dr. s Kamdar for his
presentation I would also like to thank
lab roots for making today's educational
webcast possible before we go I want to
let everyone know that today's webcast
will be available for on-demand viewing
through June 15th 2018 you will receive
an email from lab roots letting you know
when this webcast will be available for
replay please show that an announcement
with your colleagues who may miss
today's live event that is all for now
thank you for joining us we hope to see
you again soon goodbye